Of those 10 things you've mentioned,
could you now tell us which is
considered to be the most serious and
sinful act which invalidates the fast?
The act which is the most sinful and
most serious amongst all of them which
invalidate the fast it is sexual
intercourse.
that when you have sexual intercourse
and when the two private parts meet then
your fast is invalidated
whether ejaculation takes place or not
and you have to repent for that you have
to complete the fast for that day and
you have to make it up later and you
have to pay a penalty that's kafara
according to the say hadith in which a
beloved prophet said it's mentioned in
say bkari volume number three in the
book of fasting Hadit number 1936 where
a man comes to the prophet and says that
I am ruined. Oh prophet I am ruined. The
prophet says what is the matter? The man
says I had sex with my wife while I was
fasting. So the prophet says that can
you free a slave? So the man says no I
cannot.
Then the prophet asks can you fast
consecutively for 2 months? Can you fast
continuously for 60 days? The man says,
"No, I cannot." Then the prophet says
that
can you feed 60 poor people?
And the man says, "No." And the hadith
continues. In short, we come to know
from this hadith that if any person does
a sexual intercourse, it is one of the
major sins. It is the most serious and
sinful amongst all the things that break
the fast. The person who does this sin,
he should immediately repent to Allah
subhana wa t'ala and ask for
forgiveness. He should complete his fast
for that day and make up for that fast
later on after Ramadan and he has to pay
a penalty and the penalty we come from
this hadith is that he either frees a
slave if he can. If he does not have the
money to free the slave or he cannot
find a slave to free then he should fast
for two consecutive months.
Fast for 60 days. If he cannot do that
also then you should at least feed 60
poor people.
And these are the three options that
have been given for a person to pay as a
penalty as a kafara. But if a person can
do the first thing, he should not jump
to the second or the third. The first is
freeing a slave. If he cannot do that,
if he doesn't have the money or cannot
find a slave, then he can go to the next
option that is fasting consecutively for
60 days. If he cannot do that, if he's
unable to do that, continuously fasting
for 60 days. If he fasts for a few days
and then one day he doesn't fast, he
should start again. He should fast
consecutively for 60 days. If he doesn't
have the capacity to do that, then what
he can do is he can feed 60 poor people
and each poor person should be fed with
approximately half s. Each sa is equal
to three handful of ostretched hand or
feet. So half sa per person or the food
that is there of the land. So 60 poor
people you should feed. This is the
kafara, the penalty for a person who
breaks a fast by having a sexual
intercourse.
>> The amount of food just to clarify that
for my own benefit if you like.
>> Do you think that that's equivalent to
about a day's food approximately?
>> In short, it should be a day's food
that's normal in that land. It may
change in America. It may change in UK.
It may change in India. But at that time
it was like one of these says that one
man requires half s of meat and each sa
of meat is outstretched two hands if
outstretched and the amount of wheat
that comes in that's equal to sa so half
of three. The other hadithi says that
one mud of meat that is equal to one
outstretched hand of wheat. The other
hadith says that equivalent to fill a
poor man's appetite you know his
stomach. So in short you should feed a
poor person 60 poor people you should
feed approximately what is the food of
that land that you should feed him
>> and if you can't find people in your
land who are poor then you look for the
nearest place or
>> yes anywhere and that's difficult in
today's world that you cannot find 60
people to feed I don't any place in the
world where you cannot find 60 people to
feed it may not be locality but if you
just go to the next locality in your
city surely in your country surely you
can find I wish to Allah
may that time come.
>> Amen. Amen.
>> Which will come in.